false alarm The Voice talked about the
city it was a radio announcers voice and
I resented it's clean diction and its
wheedling salesmanship the voice of
warning spoke to the people of the city
as though it were trying to sell him a
laxative a tube of toothpaste the cake
of soap for a pack of cigarettes there
was a cold voice aloof and precise and I
knew the announcer had spent a lot of
time the vocal teachers the voice told
the people of the city to stay off the
streets to be calm to remain in their
homes until the all-clear had sounded
the voice said unidentified planes had
been spotted beating toward the city
those planes I thought of coming to bomb
my family and my friends to try and
destroy the city I love we sat there in
the barracks waiting to go on God and we
cursed the planes and I felt angry and
helpless I loved the city beyond all
places I'm not a man for country places
and the choir of the crickets annoys me
late at night because I want to hear the
roaring ebb and flow of Broadway I like
to hear the L trains in the distance and
even after they tore down the structure
I used to listen for them and feel sad
when I couldn't hear they're rolling
clatter the noise of Brook makes is not
for me I want the music in the Stork
Club
I see more beauty in the lights of the
city than I do in the stars in the sky I
want to see the dawn and the windows of
the Empire State Building all the hills
in the world can't stir me the way the
big buildings do it was a false alarm
the planes never came but that polite
radio announces voice pronouncing the
warning made me hate the enemies of
democracy more than anything else ever
will I'd always thought of war being
fought on strange lands and parched
fields or in faraway mud I thought of it
as something that happened to remote
cities where other people lived although
I have always thought our life and our
property were in jeopardy I never
imagined New York under fire I do now I
think of my family and my friends in the
city I loved every time I take a rifle
in my hands and every time I fixed my
bayonet as the warning voice droned and
Sam Levinson's radio I thought of mr.
Durkin who lived in our house on Hudson
Street when I was a child he was a
bricklayer bricklayer stupid from trou
Morna I thought of him on a thin Ladda
in the skeleton of a building I thought
of the ladder buckling and breaking and
mr. Durkin falling I remembered him
coming home mangled and bandaged and how
difficult it was to get the stretcher up
the narrow stairs I thought how hard mr.
Durkin worked to build these edifices
which are the symbol of our civilization
I thought of the pride he had in them I
remembered him on a Sunday afternoon
taking me by the hand and showing me one
the white strips still crossed on the
windows the dust from the bricks rising
in a fog about the foundation I thought
of the sweat in the blood mr. Durkin had
put into these buildings I thought of
the architects dreams a single plane
coming out of the mists at Sandy Hook
could destroy all that mr. Durkin worked
for and had pride in one bomb might fall
and all the skill and strength all the
living and the dying all the sweat and
the beauty and the dream would vanish
and the winter wind would carry the dust
away I thought of that and I thought of
those who Snicket at the likes of me
they mocked the pieces I wrote about the
army they said I was a sucker because I
stayed in when I was over 28 he could
have gone out there were the
isolationists and they said we were a
people apart and we were immune to
invasion and fire what did they say then
what did they think what was in their
minds as the announcers voice spoke the
warning did they say these buildings
would not fall these people will not die
the city will not be bombed did they say
we are the people apart then I hope they
said we are wrong and we admit it we are
a united people now and we must make up
for what we did we were guilty we will
work for forgiveness in my outfit most
of the guys are from the city they
telephone their families and they were
angrily glad the warning had been false
but on the field as we went through a
bayonet drill the noncoms didn't have to
drive us we grunted with pleased
exertion as we made the long thrust and
the short thrust in the jab the war had
come to the city and we were part of the
city
it's Jimmy cannon 1943